[Music]
let's talk a little bit about the finale
how did you feel about that ending it
looks when he took on that scene had a
couple different forms like when we
first got the white draft he was
different from what it was pretty
different from what it ended up being
there were more people involved like but
ended up becoming very much clay and
Tyler and which I think was really kind
of important because I think we're
supposed to know and believe that what
clay did is the wrong decision to make
they should have called the police they
should have locked they should have just
locked the doors inside and called the
police and and and let everyone know it
was happening I mean I think that we are
not supposed to believe that clay made
the right decision even though it was
ultimately successful but we're supposed
to believe that that is a decision that
clay would make because he is someone
who acts on his emotions without
thinking his actions through before he
does them and really tries to take
everything on himself and I think he was
trying to make up for mistakes he made
in the past by not being there for
someone really needs it and that's what
he's saying when you hear the narration
of his speech from Hannah's memorial
service that day yeah and so clay just
feels a responsibility to go and save
anyone he can and in doing that they
could have been it could have been an
extreme disaster so and I mean I don't
think clay really knew what he was
getting into by walking outside but I
think he really fully realized in a
moment that he'd be facing Tyler with an
assault rifle right in front of him but
you know he could have called the police
and someone altom Utley did inside as we
know because the police are on the way
but you know I just any it's it's a
tricky scene because Mia's Dillon I'm
going that what is this is a horrible
decision like what what is clay doing
but then you also have to really believe
what you're doing in in playing clay in
that scene so I have to really kind of
get to a place of believing what I'm
doing is right to when in the scene but
I don't know I mean as long as people
know that like that's we know that that
is not the right decision you know and
nobody should ever try and go and
confront anyone who is carrying a weapon
so how do you feel about people who are
criticizing the show for almost
empathizing with Tyler's character and
his intent to even go yeah I mean I
don't know I think like no one's
opinions are invalid I think that anyone
who has an opinion and had a starting
discussion than is debating this with
someone I think that's healthy mm-hmm
you know I can't really speak on why
certain decisions are made on the show
the way they are I just have to you know
kind of be there and believe in what
we're doing and I do I mean I think it's
it's a way of it's a way of how you look
at it and if you're empathizing with
Tyler and I mean like obviously you're
not on anyone else's side in the
bathroom scene
but it's it's more about it for me it's
not really about empathizing Tyler but
just recognizing that there are many
different ways that a monster can be
formed or that's what can bring a
monster out of someone and to me the way
that I view this season overall is how
like involving weapons and everything is
how dangerous it can be when kids who
are so destructive and so emotionally
confused can easily access weapons like
this and really what weapons of mass
destruction like like assault rifles and
that is that's at least how I view this
and I would like to see that discussed
in future seasons or at least be
addressed because I've been saying it's
like it's it this show it is difficult
because it's it's like it has to walk if
I mind you it can't be it can't be just
a PSA or shoving messages on people's
throats or else then it's just not
compelling televisions like you have to
find this this rap this fine line where
it's compelling TV and also discussing
the topics that it does with with truth
I mean with with grace and I think that
could be addressed and I think it will
be and that's just how I view it yeah
how did you feel about the bathroom
scene when you first read it I mean it's
gotten a lot of people talking yeah yeah
I mean I remember when I heard about the
idea I was like I don't think there's
any way that's gonna make it in I would
be shocked
I remember reading the script and
reading it being halfway through and
then seeing the Tyler first gets his
head bashed into the mirror and then in
the sink twice and then dragged to the
toilet and its head dunked in and I and
I was thinking myself oh they totally
did this because they got rid of the mop
bit because I want to and then it got to
the mop head as well
I remember schooling just not being
prepared for the extinct that that scene
goes to it's just it's really really
brutal and I remember just being shocked
and angry and confused and conflicted on
whether I thought it needed to be there
but then the more I talked to Brian and
talked to everyone I understood why it
was there and and I really and I think
that it was shot really tastefully I
mean Kyle Alvarez is such a amazing
director he also did the finale season
one which is really tricky and I think
just the way it was shot is the best way
that it could have been done but I
remember just being feeling the emotions
that I think we're supposed to feel when
we either read or watch that scene in
this shocked confused angry sad
disturbed
you